[Musique]
ils mangent dernier megan et harry libre
et sur six pièces unitaires bio
événement à la présentatrice culte de la
télévision américaine oprah winfrey une
interview très attendue par des millions
d'américains mais aussi d'anglais
d'européens qui avait envie de
comprendre leur route coeur avec la
famille royale si je n'en parlais pas je
serais passé à l'acte je ne voulais plus
être en vie établie qui était aussi un
coup médiatique fort avec des enjeux
financiers colossaux pour c'est par
exemple qu'oprah winfrey a réalisé cette
interview pour la modique somme de 7 à 9
millions de dollars watts mais si le
coût peut officiellement rien touché
pour cette interview oprah winfrey
serait en train de préparer un
documentaire exclusif avec harry pour
apple qui pourrait leur rapporter gros
et si dans l'interview harry se
plaignait que la famille royale lui
couper les vivres le couple a tout de
même pu s'acheter une maison à 14
millions d'euros avec les économies dari
et les amoureux ont signé un contrat
avec n'explique 200 millions de dollars
c'est si simple et si enrichissant sans
compter que cette interview a confirmé
l'intérêt du public pour le couple et
leur histoire
selon david laigle patron de braine
finances le coût pourrait peser encore
plus l'eau dans les années à venir il
pourrait devenir une entité d'un
milliard de dollars au cours de la
décennie à venir s'ils décident est de
faire de la publicité pour des produits
cosmétiques ou des lignes de vêtements
par exemple
visiblement même loin de maman harry
semble s'en sortir comme un grand alors
évidemment c'est un tabou a fait
beaucoup parler alors ce qui est amusant
c'est que visiblement au niveau
financier
ça va prendre à la réunion ils ont pris
5 6 millions là enfin bon il reste une
heure et demie de roche n'a les traités
par oprah winfrey apporter 60 millions
de ventes dans le monde entier
alors il faut quand même plein ces
pauvres petits parce que je crée oui le
père le père le père de harry a coupé
les vivres ont dit comment s'en sortir
quand on s'appelle un arrêt immédiat
c'est compliqué regarder alors la plus
on ne pourra pas à pas on l'a pas on l'a
pas la bd mais non mais moi je comprends
tout à fait je suis désolé vous êtes
papa
vous avez quatre enfants vous allez pas
arrêté de donner de l'argent à l'un des
quatre ont fait tout le temps la même
chose pour les 4 à partir du moment où
le prince charles
continuez à donner de l'argent à rouhia
c'est normal
exemple je lance un appel monfils simon
qui m'attend travail et gerda tu n'auras
plus tard on n'a jamais douté
communication et alors est ce qu on va
voir la photo qui est derrière vous
regardez bien le prince harry natia pas
quelque chose qui vous choque
lui c'est aux parents de panache et que
ces chaussures sont usés et que ça va il
a mis ça exprès toute communication de
[Rires]
bakou mais ça on sait vraiment qui est
un mec payer une blinde atomique il à
dire alors mon prince et et les
chaussures de merde
les chaussées sont en coton également je
suis désolé oui oui bien soit remonté
sur scène jusqu'au c'est à une
information regardez excusez moi mais
ils étaient ils auraient déjà être sur
son 31 comme hambourg est dépassé a pris
ses chaussures chez moi ça c'était plus
un rond quand je dis ça personne ne l'a
ni cet instant je vous le dis vous
l'avez très bien dit c'est vrai que ils
ont vendu entre 7 et 9 millions d'euros
de dollars
cette interview mais le couple et ont
touché combien votre avis soit du couple
ouais 340000 en résine contrat les
détenus avec des tricks 200 millions je
vous dis aussi sont fait avoir par oprah
winfrey qui le coache compris que 300000
dollars
c'est que c'est vraiment d'hermann de là
mais l'accord avec la série documentaire
sur les maladies manquements moi je vous
dis franchement cette interview bon
était sympathique